the power plant doesn't have energy it
generates energy and I've been teaching
that for like 15 years on stage and one
guy stands up one time and he goes
actually you're wrong at my event
there's 2 000 people in my bed he goes
well you're actually wrong I'm like oh
how am I wrong he says well a power
plant doesn't generate energy what it
does is it takes energy from One Source
upgrades it so it transforms the energy
then stores it and transmits it so it's
really transforming energy from one
location to another and I love that
metaphor because I felt like that's my
job so much of my life is helping people
reach another level of energy because if
you don't reach out of energy you can't
serve at another level if you don't
reach another level of energy you can't
feel better be happier be a better
spouse everyone says I want that next
level but they don't understand energy
is the requirement to get there and when
we measured energy in our studies we're
talking about really mental energy
emotional energy and physical energy it
was a huge turning point in my life when
I started realizing these things because
that whole thing that we as
entrepreneurs we want to wait for maybe
one day all feel energized or maybe one
day I'll feel Joy or maybe one day I can
have fun after you know all the money's
in the bank you got the house or the
cars or the money and then people go
then I'm gonna be really a fun person
it's like no if you're not a fun person
when you're broke you're not going to be
that much more fun when you're rich I
think that people have to learn to bring
the joy it's one of our little tag
Glides on our shirts right bring the joy
and that says you don't have joy just
like I don't think people have happiness
I don't think people have sadness either
I think that we are generating the
emotions and the feelings that we
experience in life as soon as we own
that responsibility life gets really fun
need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe Nation because I love it hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something so get ready to seek Clarity
decide to change and raise necessity
with Brendan burchard and my take on his
top 10 rules of success to give you the
confidence motivation and belief that
you need enjoy
rule number two know how to execute and
scale creativity
is not strongly correlated with high
performance
and if you told me that seven years ago
I would have fought with you for like
two or three hours
but then uh in one interview with one of
the world's largest uh ctOS Chief
technology officer she said Brennan you
know they're they're top 10 brand in the
world except we we don't uh is it my
team he said I'm not creative my team's
not creative but we know how to execute
and scale
and execution and scale is really
important to long-term high performance
creativity might get you in the game but
a lot of people are creative but can't
work their way out of the bag and I was
like I would argue that forever because
I'm a creative writer and a coach I
would have never thought that rule
number three have discipline if you're
not doing block time here's what your
day might look like you have all these
different Slots of time right and you're
just going to plug in as you go through
the day you're going to plug in oh I'll
work some there and I'll work some there
and then I'll try to cram stuff up right
at the end of the day I'll try to cram
that sucker in any crammers crammers
crammers crammers okay just checking no
judgment no judgment you're just not
going as fast as you could that's all
crammers they're I love cramers yeah
just like because they're easy to get to
move faster because you do have that
diligence of when there's a deadline and
it's on you can go which really serves
you but we gotta take you from a Cramer
to a preparer to a high performer and
the way that we do that is is to look at
this and go listen if you keep leaving
all these time slots to randomness
what happens
is they start to get filled
with the Big D
distraction
[Applause]
some reason it seems like this hit home
for some people
I don't know why how many recognize what
I'm talking about here
so now
you add up take this out
you might not be thinking too seriously
about it but let's say that's like a day
one two three four five six seven eight
work hours
you didn't know I drew that on purpose
if you leave your time to Randomness you
are stealing from your greatness
if you leave your time to Randomness you
are stealing from your greatness bit by
bit hour by eight hour day by day week
by week month by month quarter by
quarter year by year and decade by
decade and it's the little things like
this where you're like oh my gosh I
didn't get anything done because you've
got all these random approaches to your
day rule number four make conscious
decisions your life doesn't end up an
accident your life is a series of
actions that you initiate or don't
initiate
and that your thoughts are going to
control that road map and so how are you
using your mind today to either make
yourself feel great or not I posted on
Instagram this morning I said listen
your destiny is ultimately controlled to
by a decision you already made this
morning everyone watching this already
made a decision this morning this
morning they made it a life-changing
huge decision this morning and that is
either
I'm going to get up
enter the world with no intention
go through the motions to hopefully get
by or survive or I am going to get clear
in this morning about what I want what
I'm going after who I'm going to be how
I'm going to serve and whether or not
I'm going to be excellent and
extraordinary
or not
and the problem is most people never
make that conscious decision so and so I
was learning early on make the conscious
decision about who you want to be each
day
congruent with that
and that was you know for me a kid who's
just going through the motions all of a
sudden going oh who do I want to be what
do I want my relationships to be like
that was really important and then I
started setting personal challenges
every month also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five don't look for
gratitude I'm a writer I'm a coach and
I'm a trainer
my job is to share things that are
relevant to the teaching point
so it's what am I trying to teach now
I'll share case studies about my life or
some research uh but it's pretty limited
towards only what I'm teaching and
people sign up for me to teach a very
specific thing
so they're not seeing the whole picture
of my life they're just learning that
specific thing so I think it also left a
lot of people going
okay he's super successful but I don't
know anything about it right right and
that created try to trust people you
don't know anything about yes and or you
read the motivation Manifesto right
there is no Brendan in that book The
Publisher turned famously turned down
the book we had a two million dollar
book deal I turn in the book and the
editor goes what the hell is this you
you wrote it like it's you know
1776. you're not there's not one story
of you in here your audience wants to
know about you I'm like yeah but that's
not what I'm writing for I'm writing for
the art and so they said we can't
publish and we can't mark this book is
unmarketable so you wrote a two million
dollar check back wrote it back which is
painful because I already spent it
um but anyway I sold a million copies
yeah then we went into 30 weeks uh 32
weeks on the New York Times best seller
list so they turned it down with no
publisher well I guess you had like a
yeah we went to Hay House yeah they
supported it and distributed it and did
a great job on it I love them and their
Community really got behind the book
because they knew I wrote it for the art
not for the I didn't sell out on the
book it was this was my artist my art
has never been like talking about
Brendan my art has been I want to teach
but I want to teach in a way that really
hits you in the heart and gives you
habits that you can Implement in your
life
but that also took me out of the picture
a little bit because I didn't want to be
the guru I didn't want to be you know
I'm from Montana we're pretty private
there and one of our main sayings there
is you know the time to have the map is
before you enter the woods
so I just wanted to hand people the map
I didn't want to hand people like look
at me
um I also had a big influence for my
high school journalism teacher and she
said there's two kinds of people
one who walks into room and goes here I
am
and the other person walks into room and
goes there you are rule number six raise
necessity necessity is kind of short for
performance necessity
um or what we call psychological
necessity which means there is a moment
in which you are serving people or
you're trying to achieve your goal or
your dream in which now it is not a
preference
it's a must
right but to use better languaging it's
it becomes necessary for us to excel in
this like it's not a hope anymore it's
not I I I it should do it it becomes so
necessary that it connects with our
identity
that we feel it is necessary for me to
deliver with Excellence here because
that is who I am
it's necessary for me to deliver with
Excellence here because somebody needs
me
to do well it's necessary for me to do
well here because this topic this thing
I'm doing I'm passionate about this I
care about this I want to master this
I'm obsessed with this and it's
necessary for me to do well because of
the time it's it's a deadline or it's go
time or and when all those come together
that show that personal side of this is
my identity and obsessed about it and
that other side where it's like somebody
needs me and there is a real deadline
right in the middle
that's performance necessity and we when
we hit that
the game changer rule number seven
change your interpretations in our lives
especially when we're being
reactive
information comes in right we're at an
event we're paying attention to how
people treat us
we're studying something we're trying to
learn something and we're just going
about a regular day information is
coming in how people perceive us the
cause and effective events
things are just happening information
comes into the brain from that point the
information immediately
goes into
interpretation
and what this usually means is
interpretation in the fast reactive
thing is safe unsafe good
bad
like it
don't like it recognize it don't
recognize it
been there done that unfamiliar or
familiar certain uncertain fear safe all
these things start triggering it's
pretty unconscious and it's pretty fast
our biases come into play it's just that
speed spontaneous reactive part of us
and it's that's not always bad sometimes
it can be good
right sometimes it can be good
interpretation can be that event that's
good for me or that events that's bad
for me but usually it's like a snap
judgment think about that most most when
we're talking about an unconscious level
it's like a snap judgment automatic like
you like her or don't like her feel safe
don't feel safe it's very fast
then the next level and this is not
always linear of course because your
brain is not left brain right brain kind
of methodology your brain's more of a
spider web of interconnectedness that is
something we still don't understand okay
you can study everything in neuroscience
and you might learn something about this
lobe or that that cortex region but then
only to find out that later on a year
later like well actually it seems like
it's also communicating over here it's a
spider web of unbelievable intelligence
that's happening that and everything can
be millisecond hundreds of million
seconds
of transitions between neural networks
it's unbelievably fast unbelievable
capable so this is just for our
understanding it's not necessarily real
world linear like this but what tends to
happen is as information comes in good
bad we also then move it to
a level of well what does this mean to
me
identity
what does this mean to me what does this
either mean to me or what does this say
about me
how does this apply to me
and if we're not conscious here this is
going to be really Troublesome some of
you discovered that yesterday I bet when
you released a few things sometimes we
have these events in our life that we we
take on and we just assume it meant
something about us and we didn't realize
no that's more of a statement about them
than it is about us right sometimes when
you're hurt or someone was rude to you
it had nothing to do with you raise your
hand you follow
I had nothing to do with you but if
you're not careful you could say mean
person unsafe means I'm bad child
rude Behavior
uncertain about this I must not be long
terrible situation
I feel bad
I can never be safe again
how many follow how this happens
this is why we have to be very very very
observational of our own thoughts and
feelings because how these things get
labeled can really change our lives
forever my friend Evan Carmichael's book
listen humans are built to serve some
people are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them but in either case
humans are built to serve so if you're
not happy right now is because you're
not serving enough you got to pick up
this book because it's so inspiring to
remind you that we're all here to
contribute to make a difference to make
an impact and this is your field guide
for that rule number eight seek Clarity
High performers seek clarity
more often than their peers and what
that means for them is every situation
they go into they're seeking Clarity and
setting intention
and it's not like once in a while
they're doing way more often it's like
uh you know I've been blessed to work
with Oprah Winfrey
when she has a meeting
at the start of every meeting she asks
what's Our intention here
what's the intention this meeting not
what's the agenda what about what's the
intention that's every meeting so she's
seeking Clarity at the beginning of
every meeting that's why she says
amazing right if you think about her
whole career she was always trying to
have people see Clarity on who they were
so they could be themselves
that's what high performers are doing
they just do it more often they see
Clarity before they shoot that video
before they have the podcast interview
um but specifically we found three
practices help you get better at seeking
Clarity number one they are seeking
Clarity in what we call the future for
so you've probably heard that successful
people are more future-minded it's true
and specifically what they're looking at
if you talk to a high performer they're
more clear about
um who do I want to be
in this upcoming situation and by the
way it's not about who I am
it's about who do I want to be they're
more future oriented they're more
intentional about who they want to be in
social situations
so it's like I want to have this type of
interaction with Lewis today that that's
intentional they're more clear
about what skills they need to develop
to reach their next level of success
right
here's how you really know an
underperformer open up their calendar
and look for any evidence they have
planned their own curriculum for
greatness
if they don't have classes or courses if
they if they're not actively skill
building
there's no chance at high performance
rule number nine decide to change people
take an eye-opening experience and some
don't do anything with it and some
people grow from it and I came back from
that experience I was in college and
prior to going back I was a depressed
kid the sad kid the kind of the Lonely
kid kind of the pull away from the world
kid because I was hurt I came back
and I had this new intention to live so
I wanted to meet people and talk to
people they're like who are you and
anytime you change your life usually
people are like what's wrong with you
someone's like what's wrong with you but
I was like I'm Gonna Change
because I knew I didn't want misery
anymore I didn't want suffering I didn't
want sadness I didn't want negative
thinking I didn't want poor quality of
relationships I didn't want to feel
horrible so I began the quest of well
how do I not feel horrible
so I started reading first I started
personal development self-help then
jumped into spirituality then jumped
into psychology then jumped into
Neuroscience then jumped into sociology
then jumped into leadership and spent
every week for 23 years I read a book a
week on one of those topics
for 23 years I went to the seminars
about the audio courses so I'm listening
to Dale Carnegie and Napoleon Hill and
Earl Nightingale and Jim Rohn and Zig
Zigler and Louise Hay and Marianne
Williamson and Debbie Ford and and Tony
Robbins and Wayne Dyer Deepak Chopra
Brian Tracy and I went down deep like
I'm very much like you I'm obsessive
so I got obsessive into psychology Carl
Rogers Alfred Adler Roy baummeister
Abraham Maslow all of the positive
psychology work that was developing at
the time that was becoming bigger and
bigger and bigger and Rule Number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is be careful about your intentions
from here once we've kind of looked
through that lens and again this is
going to be unconscious and super Speedy
but once we kind of information comes in
good bad here's what it means to me we
tend to then from there
set an intention
which means
so what do I want to do with this
information
intention
what's my next action from this or what
am I going to do in the future because
of this
and intentions can be very unhealthy too
intentions can be like we talked about
yesterday
sometimes if this is wired wrong
or this goes in a in a way that doesn't
support us sometimes that intention is
I'm going to protect myself
I am never going to share who I am
because that one person or those people
hurt my feelings or did that thing and
all of a sudden our intentions become
completely self-protective I talked
about yesterday how people button up or
they put on the face mask or they build
up the walls the bad guys and then who
can't get in
the good guys like I said yesterday
sometimes in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing that we so
desperately desire
connection
but a lot of people's intention has been
throughout their lives because they
weren't observing their thoughts became
completely tilted towards safety
so they think there's a big difference
between
wanting to be safe and operating from
Fear
accountability means you know what my
credit card bills those are mine I'm
accountable for handling those instead
of avoiding them I am personally
responsible to deal with these even if I
didn't cause all these problems
I am now the person who if I'm going to
clear the problems off my plate I gotta
take some personal accountability for
that
I am now the person who gets to choose
my attitude today
I am now the person who expects myself
to follow a higher standard and to
follow through
accountability personal responsibility
or personal accountability says okay
I'm going to own this reality I'm going
to plan my way through it I'm going to
follow through
and I'm going to set up checks and
balances to make sure I do that
where that's setting goals and tracking
and measuring the goals and my own
behavior towards those goals
or getting a coach
sharing socially in the community or
talking with your friends and family and
putting it out there now your butt's on
the line and you got to do it
I think that's what's important
so often
we say you know
I have dreams I'm not going to tell
anybody
and often in person development you hear
people say no tell people
because once you verbalized it you can
realize it once you've verbalized it and
it's socialized now there's an
expectation you follow through
here's my question too
do you have enough expectations
to follow through
often when I work with CEOs
as as their executive coach what ends up
happening is
they have that kind of
maybe they have investors and their
investors expect them to stay on path
maybe they need to hit their quarterly
goals
um but winds up happening is sometimes
they start feeling like their
accountability
is driven by others and often High
performers feel all these obligations
they are accountable but they're
accountable to obligations that other
people have set
and if you want a real fast track to
being demotivated
stop setting
your own plan
stop setting your own accountability
this is why for me as I told you I go in
my plan section of growth every day I
look at all those plans I'm like
I'm behind on this
but I don't get discouraged I just make
a plan on how to handle it
sometimes I look at them like I don't
like my score here with my friends I I
went three months without really talking
to my friends I don't get down on myself
I make a plan
I don't fall prey to that victim part of
myself it says but all these other
things are happening and oh my God I
just go okay got it I don't like that
I'm the only one in charge of the ship
you're the only one in charge of those
scores
and once you realize that you're like
okay
I'm accountable what's my plan because
sometimes you left your accountability
to your boss you left your
accountability to your manager you left
your accountability to your spouse you
left your accountability to the kids you
left your accountability to somebody
else and you didn't internally own it
anymore if you've ever been by seminars
before I'll talk about this for a while
and then I'll get the whole audience up
we'll play this music we'll do the
lights and all of a sudden we'll have
everyone start shouting I own my dream I
own my dream I own my dream
to help them realize again
they're the owner of their life
you own your dream you own that impulse
in your heart that says to get better
once you are the CEO of your life
not just a follower
everything shifts for us
and that's accountability if you don't
feel this day it's very likely tomorrow
you're gonna be like I don't feel
purpose
and you forgot that feeling the moments
of life that's presence
is part of purpose
and to feel them even more you bring an
intention to it
right to feel the day you have to have
the intention to feel the day right
intention precedes feeling
but most people don't know that they
have a feeling then set an intention
I don't like this feeling I'm going to
change
but when you become more conscious you
say oh I'm I'm going to enter this next
situation intentional it asks what is it
that I would love to experience or make
happen
in this next moment
oh like I'm gonna go play with the kids
or I'm gonna go teach my kids math okay
I'm gonna go teach my kids math let me
not just show up plop the book down look
at me go what are we doing but instead
save yourself okay
I'm about to go teach my kid math
how would I like to do that as a parent
how would I like to show up
what would I like that learning
experience to feel like between us
father and son mother and daughter
what would what do I want that to feel
like
even if they don't learn well today
what do I want the end
of our learning session to feel like
for them
what Association do I want them to
create
with learning math today
now notice that took me I think I
clocked it right just under 30 seconds
to ask those questions of myself
intentional living doesn't take that
much longer it's like a beat before
going into situation
you know let me
take a second here
to enter the situation more
intentionally
that is the process of bringing purpose
to a situation
right now I'm using and replacing the
word intention with purpose for a
specific reason because people get all
lost in Airy Fairyland when they talk
about purpose but ultimately purpose
looks a lot like daily intention
and the more daily intention you have
research shows the more you say you have
a purposeful life
notice it doesn't say you earn more
built more did more it says the more
daily intention you have
the more you sense your life is
purposeful when we don't have a vision
for next week next month next year life
can start to feel like we're just in you
know kind of in the swamp
and they were just going through the
motions and oh my God I'm working so
hard Brendan or oh my God man I have all
these reasons to be happy I I I already
have the great kids I I have a house I
can afford the car payments I mean I
have all these reasons to be happy but I
don't know something's missing I don't
feel purpose either
it's usually a disconnect or lack of
clarity
about your future
and I don't mean 10 years out or 50
years out I mean sometimes next month
and next year
really just sometimes it's just a couple
months Horizon and lacking Clarity and
connection with just the next couple
months or in some cases if you're a
longer term strategic kind of guy
the next year or two
I can feel that if I feel a disconnect
from my next year or two
I tend to lose a connection with purpose
a connection with motivation
uh I feel like the intentions or the
productivity of the day are kind of like
for what
you know it's easy to go I'm working so
hard but for what
and that for what
I know equals vision
what is the vision of your next couple
months or next couple years
no one will give you that
it's time to sit down and think about
that it's why you all know I keep a
battle board over here on the wall and
my Battle Board is like it's basically
like a a
arts and crafts version of a yearly
schedule
it's like it's like
about your paper with 12 boxes drawn on
it and the 12 boxes each represents one
month of the year and I create themes
across the boxes I write the major
projects and deadlines up on the boxes
and I write a bunch of my values up
there and all I do is every day I just
kind of stare at it
I'm a person who is I'm really good any
person's here you're really good at just
living in the moment
I know a lot of people aren't good at
that but I'm really good
at just being here in the moment I've
had to teach myself to do that I'm not
as good
of making sure I'm connected to my
vision
or to a longer term plan
I I'm like I'm like in the moment I'm a
happy-go-lucky kid
but if I lose connection to the vision
to the Future the happiness goes down
I also see the luck tends to go down
when you're disconnected from a vision
so what do I do I force myself every day
when I come into this office
um I like in a home studio here when I
walk in I stare at that
for like and I force myself to stare at
it and think for five minutes I have a
little notepad next to me and I look at
where everything is lining up over the
next year sometimes the next two years
and I just look at it I mean if you
walked in I mean it's really not an
attractive thing I'm kind of this
I'm just standing there kind of dumb
looking just looking at like hoping
something comes into the brain that day
walking through each month even if I saw
it yesterday
I'm still going I'm just forcing myself
to look out
you know why people tend to be motivated
January 1st
because they're looking out again and
they hadn't done it for a while if the
people around you tend to be healthy
whether that is emotionally healthy
mentally healthy physically healthy your
odds go way up especially the odds of
conscientious discipline and design your
ability to surround yourself with people
who are in a good place is one of the
great gifts of our life we are social
animals a lot of what we do in life is a
memetic meaning we kind of copy what we
see of others we set expectations on
ourselves of what we see of others a lot
of our behaviors our habits our mental
models are really a fact of sociology
and when you understand that the people
you surround yourself with you talk with
you look at you work out with you're
around you're healthier I am a greatly
healthier person in my life because of
my wife and for most men out there or
those who are Partners in couples where
one other partner is healthier than the
other that's one of the greatest Gifts
of all time you know I'm a way healthier
person I don't think I knew what kale
was until I met Denise I had no idea
broccoli what how come dark like that
there are no cheese on it so that was
important for me to learn a lot about
all of my friends in the health and
wellness category like being around them
all the time and seeing their posts and
their Instagrams or being at conferences
and studying their work or going to
conferences they're about health
surrounding myself in the ecosystem is
made me healthier it really has if you
look at where I grew up to where I am
now I mean it's totally different pure
set and that was by Design you might not
get to choose your biology or all your
family but you get to choose your peers
and your friends and The Inspirations
who you follow or learn from especially
in this category of Health once you have
that energetic Vision I promise you'll
surround yourself with better people the
first big gate of personal development
that I believe everybody goes through in
their own journey to maturity happiness
fulfillment aliveness connection with
others ultimate life satisfaction that
first gate of awareness is I'm so the
first gate of personal change is
awareness
is awareness now I know some of you
already know this but think about this
in any given moment we can be aware of
our feelings
of our environment
of how our emotions are affecting our
minds of our decision making of our
surroundings of God of Universe of
connection to this very moment in any
given moment awareness can ebb and flow
can't it
and sometimes in your life I know some
of you feel this way you're going so
fast there's so much on your plate
you're so busy at home and at work
everything's going 90 miles an hour and
it's like it feels like you're so torn
from happiness or torn from the moment
that you don't feel connected
and that is when awareness is sort of
out the door and that's why in the last
decade the topic of mindfulness you know
went from sort of a a a sort of a subtle
art to like a societal need
and as all of the research has been
showing in the mindfulness research of
how that can make us feel more grateful
happy appreciative loving connected and
kind and resilient it's become more and
more clear that people get this
but you don't go through the gates of
awareness all the time by choice
sometimes it it's pushed upon you
um I know many of you have had that
story just like I have
in the past where you weren't ready for
change you might have been resistant to
change does anyone have any family
members team members people in your life
who are resistance to change it's just
like you're around people like why won't
my husband change or why won't my child
want to be better or why won't my kid do
better in high school or whatever it's
like we all know somebody who just
doesn't ever shift into that and what
you need to know I'm gonna make you sort
of a casual coach today or an influencer
or a leader today we'll use all that
under the term of influence today if you
want to influence others you have to
understand they're not going to start
taking action to change until they've
gone through the gate of awareness
and sometimes that gate of awareness you
can Inspire it you can role model it and
sometimes life just has to happen for
them we all know people like that it's
not a judgment sometimes you can't be
responsible for everybody else in their
lives you've got to let life be their
educator if you think about the maybe
the three biggest times of your life
that you changed
like those big what they often call in
Psychology is inflection points
or those critical incidences
what were the three times when just
major shift happened in your life
I promise there was a major gate to
awareness opened up for you either it
was an insight and aha maybe you're like
Eckhart Tolle you're just laying in bed
and all of a sudden you know awareness
and presence enters your life a new
level of Consciousness lands on
wonderful maybe you had to go through
something it was a divorce a business
ending you got fired somebody said no
you got in a Health Challenge an
accident happened
for me as you know an accident happened
I got in a car wreck and it was the
ultimate perspective check
at that point in my life
I thought I wanted to die at that point
in my life I'd been suicidal and
depressed
at that point in my life I didn't see
that my life could ever be abundant or
happy or loving
I I didn't get it
and then that car accident bam and that
was like a knock on the head literally
that opened up my eyes and made me
realize oh I don't want to die I want to
live
I just don't know how
and that was my awareness
it was
I I want to live I don't know how but
I've got the second chance
and I understand I want to live I
understand I want to love I understand I
want to matter but I don't know how and
that began a lifelong journey in
personal development and then psychology
and then philosophy and then
neuroscience and then high performance
studies to try and just understand how
do people change
well maybe as you're listening to you
what what were those three big things
for you maybe it was a health thing
something happened with your family
maybe you that was when you went off to
school or when you had the birth of your
first child or something happened and it
shifted you into another level of
awareness that said
I want to improve
I want to get better I want to be
healthier I want to be happier and if
you haven't had that yet then let me
knock on the door a little bit and say
hey this is a great time to gain some
greater self-awareness without greater
self-awareness we aren't resilient we
aren't authentically confident we aren't
vibrant we aren't healthy we aren't able
to deal with all of the chaos without
conforming to everybody else
the moment we lack self-awareness is
when the impulse to conform to everybody
else enters the moment we lack
self-awareness we don't know how to ask
for what we need in an argument with our
partner or spouse the moment we lack
self-awareness we make a bad decision
that we knew wasn't right for us
it's always the first thing awareness I
recommend everyone get a coach at some
point because you need someone to have
that sounding board who asks you next
time
where you're at in your development
or in your progress or why are you
stunted or whether you're crushing it
and helps you tease out those lessons so
that you stay motivated and clear about
the next steps
and that's why I think it's so powerful
often the biggest shifts in our life
happen when we're accountable sometimes
it happens when you work with a coach or
some of you you become a coach I've
never been more accountable for my life
or had so many other people who come so
accountable for their life when they
became a coach because once you're a
coach you're accountable to help someone
grow and you that instantly raises up
your awareness just like many of you
when you get a teenager and you start
talking to your teenager about health or
mindset and you realize you're a little
off it makes you more accountable
because as soon as you teach it you're
even more accountable to live up to it
remember that congruence thing
it's a beautiful thing the best I ever
became in my life is once I became a
coach because once I was a coach I was
like oh level up your identity Brandon
you got to follow through on these
things you have to be congruent on them
too you can't go out on the stage all
the time Tire like come on everybody
it's like I had to learn to take care of
my health that I could literally manage
a 38 foot you know stage with thousands
of people and and for multiple days it
was like running a marathon every single
day I I had to be accountable to that
audience because I was teaching it and
it was like oh as soon as you put
yourself in a role of a leader a coach a
mentor a role model a caregiver as soon
as you're in that space you gain
positional accountability you realize oh
I better walk this talk because if I
don't walk this talk not only will they
notice I will start to dislike myself I
share that I I rarely share the the one
of the big Gates that happened for me
after my car accident it wasn't just the
car accident made me want to live love
and matter it was after the car accident
I had to sit with the reality that
I had built the life I didn't
intend to
I had
set in motion that relationship
that wasn't the right relationship
I chose the wrong person
despite some red flags
I allowed abusive language to happen in
a relationship
I allowed
um
I'd say resentment to carry on
I had done some things
and I'd experienced some things
that I didn't like and I could accept
them they did
but now I was accountable for building
that next relationship that had to be
better
[Music]
I had to make that next relationship
better it was on me I was the captain of
the ship
the director of the destiny
I was the director behind the movie Set
watching that character evolve I was
choosing
the next ACT
that's accountability that's a great
thing to have in life today I get to
share some ideas with you on health that
I've learned in my own personal Journey
but also as a high performance coach
for 16 years you know one of the
fundamental most important things that
we all want in our life
is a sense of Vitality
and that Vitality is what we want to
feel you know mentally engaged alert
focused enthusiastic we want to feel
energetically like physically
energized right physically we want to
feel a sense of that health and it's one
of really the only four things that we
all deeply desire we talk a lot about it
here in growth day that you can give
anybody anything but what we all really
truly want is aliveness that's what I
mean by vibrancy
connection with others and with
ourselves
meaningful Pursuits things that we're
doing that we enjoy or see as important
or contributing and growth like growing
as persons so all of that is really
important but that sense of aliveness I
always put that at the top of that
little diagram because it's so important
to us when we don't have a sense of
liveness even if we have amazing
relationships
when we are fatigued and wiped out we
can have the greatest marriage or
partner or spouse or intimate
relationship but
the zest isn't there
we can have a great job we can have
incredible opportunities to serve we can
love our passions and our Hobbies but if
we're wiped out it doesn't feel as good
I know you all know this
and that is why it's so important that
we focus on our health
now I want to do full disclaimers with
you I am not a doctor I'm not a
psychiatrist I'm not a neuroscientist I
am not a health advisor coach or medical
professional in any capacity
I'm a high performance coach this means
I work with people primarily on their
mindset and their habits and their
relationships please remember
anytime you have
a frustration or conflict or an argument
with another person
please remember you are dealing
with a trauma Survivor
please remember
you are living with a trauma Survivor
please remember you are working with
trauma survivors
you yourself have survived traumas and
struggles
unfortunate incidents brutalities
difficulties awful situations in your
life
you survived him you're still here
you're still working through
you're still showing up you're still
working on yourself
if you can put the humanity in the other
person and realize they have also
struggled
and more importantly survived traumas
this will allow you to now be more
compassionate empathetic
patient and understanding
because raise your hand if you think
sometimes you're in a conflict with your
spouse your partner or someone at work
and they might be acting out from old
triggers and traumas raise your hand
right you think you're fighting about
the vacuum cleaner
they're fighting about something that
happened in the fifth grade to them
raise your hand if you know what I'm
talking about
that that the person you're dealing with
in that moment we always teach like
freshmen in college about conflict
you're not actually there in the moment
with that person
one of you is probably in high school
or an elementary school
you're in a situation or a moment in
your past that's being triggered to
bring up all these emotions and you're
acting out from the emotion
that's usually unconscious for most
people isn't it true
the more therapy work the more coaching
the more perspective more
self-improvement more healing you do the
more you're aware of those things coming
up and they will come up as we'll talk
about in my next point
but if it's true that something's come
up for you and it's uncontrollable or
It's upsetting it's happening for the
other person too
I had a great
um
uh interaction with the person at work
one time
that I learned a lot
I was very much I know it's really hard
to understand but I was productivity
Brendan you know I was like man I was
getting stuff done it's hard to keep up
with me I am like I'm very I'm like I
schedule it I show up I deliver it I
schedule it I show up I deliver it and I
do it the positive mindset and I'm gonna
make it happen like that was really
really strong in who I was in my 20s
right and I remember
having this conversation and uh well
there's no better way to say it I was a
kind of a condescending jerk to somebody
at work
I was just was not nice to this person
at work
um early 20s probably
just starting my career in Consulting
and a partner at the company saw the
interaction
and she pulled me aside
and she asked a question
that changed my life
she said Brendan
if you knew that person
was dying
how would you have handled that
situation
and I was like
whoa
I mean it was like I immediately I
literally went to tears immediately the
second she saw it she said that
immediately went to tears
it's like
whoa
now let me ask you that think about the
last argument or conflict you had
what if that person was sick
what if that person
was hurt what if that person was dying
trust me I know I know how the
pessimists and the people who don't like
personal development would receive this
conversation right now oh Brendan here
he goes you know I get it trust me
you're not the first persons I've
trained on this topic oh yeah sure
Brendan now I'm supposed to every time I
think about have an argument think about
they're going to die sure it's practical
um
maybe it's not practical maybe it's
spiritual
and I say that because
there's not a single person you're
talking to who isn't dying
not a one you won't meet a person your
entire life who isn't dying
that's what we call in our work
mortality motivation
when we can see
humans is mortal
when we can realize it's a short stint
for all of us on this planet
everything can shift a little bit if you
are struggling with a sense of purpose
today
you are lacking a routine or a practice
to look at your tomorrows
raise your hand if you got that one
if you are struggling with purpose today
you're simply lacking a routine or
practice to look at your tomorrows
I tell everybody you want to be a better
leader you want to be a better parent
you want your day your health together
you want to build a bigger business you
want to earn more money you got to look
at your tomorrows way more consistently
not on January 1 or December 31st
but daily
that's why I forced myself to look at a
year calendar every day
because I'm not good at that and I know
that about myself and sometimes when
you're not good about something you need
to create a habit or a routine that you
will stick to and find some joy in so
usually before I get to that wall that
Battle Board I got a cup of green tea in
my hand because I love it
I got a journal next to me because I
love that
I love green tea and I love journaling
I'm not so good at the vision part but
I've created the routine just like on
email I've created a routine there that
helps me go through a process that I
know I need to do but I'm not as good at
y'all follow
so this is what I'm suggesting to you if
you're lacking Vision we need a practice
to look at your future more often
so critical it's why when you do that
morning mindset prompt
in growth day one of the questions asks
what's a project I should keep in mind
that I'll be doing in the future
that I might not be able to do today but
I just need to keep it on the dashboard
of my mind
and people always ask well I
when I do this thing it's kind of the
same thing every day I I gotta you know
I wrote down I'm gonna write a book one
day and I got to write it again and
again I'm like yes you have to again
then again and again think about your
future even if you're not doing anything
for today
you know even if you're not taking the
action say you have to think about
it you know right now I'm thinking I'm
working on some major media projects I'm
not doing them yet
but I'm thinking about them I take a
moment to think about that project just
try to get in the unconscious
kind of scrolling around back then to
connect me to the Future
because when you feel connected to the
Future especially when it's something
that you are choosing to go do to go
build to go manifest
you will feel more purposeful
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more Brendan burchard check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there double down on
your goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 2020 you want to find purpose
this year double down on your goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can I be a role model